Look, I get it. You're watching other
writers pump out tons of content with AI
while you're still staring at a blank
page, and you've probably got other
people telling you that it's like you're
trying to use the typewriter while
everybody else is in a computer age. And
every day this goes by, you're thinking
to yourself, "Am I just wasting time
developing writing skills that are about
to become completely useless?" Here's
what those AI writers don't want you to
know. They're all starting to sound
exactly the same. Meanwhile, you have
something that they're losing, [music]
which is the ability to think
originally. So, in today's video, I'm
going to show you exactly how to turn
that [music]
disadvantage into your biggest
competitive advantage. Because while
everyone else is racing to optimize
[music] their prompts, you are going to
master the fundamentals that actually
[music] create lasting value. More
specifically, I'm going to show you
exactly how to use your writing not just
to communicate valuable ideas, but to
actually [music] generate them. You'll
also learn how to break bad writing
habits that you learned in school to
make sure that readers can actually
perceive that value. Then, I'm going to
show you how to cut your writing time in
half using a pretty simple two-step
system that eliminates the torture of
trying to [music] write perfectly while
you're still figuring out what you
think. This video is going to let you in
on my expert writing system. And I've
broken it up into eight phases that if
we practice and master are going to help
us rise above the deluge of AI slop
that's just been flooding the market so
that we can all get back to writing that
makes a difference. [music] And this
first phase is the foundation because
you're probably sitting there thinking,
do I even have anything worth saying?
Will anybody care about my article or my
book? But here's the thing. You
absolutely have valuable knowledge.
That's not the problem. The problem
isn't what you [music] know, it's how
you're packaging it. Many of you are
writing like you're still in school
trying to impress a teacher, and that is
killing the relationship that you have
with your reader. So, in this section,
we're going to learn how to ditch all
the academic stuff that's just been
weighing you down and write like the
expert that you actually are. So here we
need to learn how to stop writing like
we're still in school because everything
that they or honestly we I'm an English
professor so I'm just as guilty as this
as anyone. I've been teaching writing
for 10 years in a university and so I
know this as well as anybody which is to
say that everything we teach you about
writing in school was for our sake.
Okay, think about the system. We have to
grade your papers. We're not real
readers. We're not reading for value. Or
rather, the things that your teachers
value are different than the things that
real readers value. Teachers value
simplicity. They value certain patterns.
We want to make it easy for us cuz we've
got to grade like hundreds of these
essays. So, we're all looking for our
own particular writing patterns. And
when you make that easy for us to find,
we give you a good grade because we can
move on quickly to the next one. That's
not how real readers work. Expert
writing works differently. It says,
"Here's the problem you're having and
here's my solution to it." Bit of a
tangent here, but do you know what the
word essay means? It comes from French.
It's the verb to try.
It means attempt or try. And when this
genre was kind of conceived, that was
the idea of it. It was like a writer is
looking at a problem and saying, "Huh, I
don't know, that's a hard problem. Let
me see. Let me try to see if I can
answer it. So, like there's no such
thing as an essay about your favorite
food or should we wear uniforms in
school. You know, these bogus topics
that we give you in essay writing at
school. Instead, at the beginning of an
essay, you should always be able to
identify the question that you're trying
to answer. And I honestly I tell my
students that they should look at that
question and say to themsel, "Huh, I
don't know." Because too often we look
at a question and we already have a
preconceived notion of what our answer
to that question is going to be. So
instead I kind of make my students
practice out loud saying I don't know
what kind of evidence would I need in
order to answer this question. Anyway,
we'll talk more about that kind of
process of discovering what you think
through writing a little bit later. But
that's the real meaning of the word
essay. But this is where so much writing
fails because many writers learn these
patterns from school and then they go
out there in the real world and it's
like they're still trying to show your
work and your knowledge instead of
giving people readers what they actually
need. One quick example of the type of
writing patterns that come out of school
is opening with a background or context.
Right? We in in our essays, we kind of
set the context. And that's a writing
pattern that appeals to teachers because
when we're writing for a teacher, we're
trying to demonstrate to them that we
understand the context of the problem.
But think about readers, like actual
readers who want to find a solution to a
problem, right? They open your essay
because the title promises them a
solution to a problem. Do they want to
read through all this background and
context? No. They want to know the
answer to their problem. They don't care
how much you know, how much you've
researched. they don't care about any of
that. So that's just one pattern that's
a kind of hangover from the writing that
we learn how to do in school and we
really need to forget that because in
the real world we're writing for
somebody different. Another pattern that
comes out of school writing is when we
explain our whole thought process. You
know, we say, "Okay, here's an
interesting question and at first I
thought this, but then I read this
article and it kind of made me think
that and then I was a little bit
confused and so I talked to my friend
and right." So you give an outline of
your whole thinking process and
ultimately the answer that you arrive at
comes at the end of the essay. But that
drives readers crazy. They don't want to
know the whole evolution of your thought
process. They want to know the answer to
the question. So those are just two
examples, background knowledge and the
process of your thinking that come out
of school writing. And we really need to
abandon that and remember our readers
and their experience as they move their
way through our text. And basically what
we need to do here is stop trying to
demonstrate what we know and the ideas
that we have and instead start helping
people make better decisions. Step two
is to understand the difference between
communication and getting results.
Because most people think that writing
is kind of like a garden hose. It's a
medium through which ideas get
transferred from one person's head to
another. I guess we have garden hoses
running between our heads in this
example. But the point here is that it's
a medium of exchange. Right? I have a
fully formed idea in my head and then I
put it into writing and then you can
decode that writing and put it into your
head. That's what some people think and
that would be the communication model of
writing. But if you think about it,
that's a pretty selfcentered version of
writing that doesn't really take into
account the reader or their interests,
anything about the reader. They're just
there to receive whatever we put into
the writing. And the reason this kind of
writing fails is that communication
assumes that the reader wants to hear
your thoughts. But if I'm honest, they
don't. They really don't. What people
really want is a little bit of help
getting from where they are to where
they want to be. Now, I don't want to
sound too utilitarian about this. Of
course, we're not all writing, you know,
how to guides, but even in the world of
ideas, we are developing solutions to
conceptual problems, right? readers are
going through the world and they're
trying to understand the way the world
works and they run into a wall
somewhere. You know, there's something
they don't understand. Well, we can
provide them an idea that gives them a
better understanding of the world. So,
even though we're not showing them how
to cook my grandmother's spaghetti or,
you know, any other kind of how-to
guide, what we're still showing them how
to do is to replace one idea with
another idea, one that will help them
better navigate the world. So instead of
a garden hose where we're just funneling
ideas from our head into the reader's
head, the texts can be more like GPS
directions, bringing them from where
they are, the reader is meeting them
where they're at and bringing them to
where we want them to be. So the way to
do this is to really stop asking the
question, how do I explain my ideas?
What's the best way of writing my ideas?
Right? Let go of our ideas. Now, of
course, I'm a big advocate of developing
your own ideas. And when we talk about
the writing process, we're going to get
into how you can use writing to generate
your own ideas. But for now, whenever
we're preparing our text for readers, we
need to let go of the idea of explaining
my ideas and start asking, how do I move
readers from point A, where they are, to
point B? And I love this idea of the
text not as a capsule of our knowledge,
but more like a map because it turns it
into a kind of journey that we usher the
reader through rather than just a brain
dump. Step three is all about value,
value, value. A lot of my coaching
clients at the beginning of our
relationship will start off obsessing
over being clear and organized, right?
They want to know, "How can I make my my
text really strong? How can I make it
concise and clear and make the ideas
really pop? But what I find they ignore
is whether anyone actually cares. We
can't worry about concision and
organization and clarity in the writing
before we've asked the question, is
there value in this? Who and who's going
to value it? Because if your text is
clear and useless, it's useless. If it's
organized and useless, it's useless. If
your text is persuasive and useless,
it's useless. Readers do not care about
clarity, organization, or persuasion.
They only care about value. And so
before we talk about any of the
mechanics of your writing, what we
really need to get clear on is where is
the value in this? Because in the real
world, of course, nobody is reading you
to give you a grade. If you're not
helping them make better decisions or
solve problems or just understand the
way the world works, then they're going
to stop reading regardless of how clear,
organized, and persuasive the language
is. All right? So, to get really
tactical about this, it's important to
ask yourself, what are readers going to
be able to do differently after this?
Now, their behavior might change or
their thinking might change. That is, if
your text solves a practical problem,
then it's going to show them how to
change their behavior in order to get
what they want. If it's a conceptual
problem, then they're going to change
their thinking, and that thinking is
going to be upstream of other behavior
that they change. More on that a little
bit later, but ultimately what we're
trying to clarify here is that value is
not what you find interesting. It's what
actually helps readers accomplish their
goals, whether that is a change in
behavior or a change in understanding.
But it's impossible to know what readers
find valuable if we don't know our
readers. So step four is all about
knowing exactly who you're writing for.
Because when I ask writers who their
audience is, they generally say
something vague like business people or
general audience or content creators,
which is like shooting at a target that
you can't even see. And this is
something that a lot of writers will
push back on me about because they
inherit some bad ideas from the world of
fiction and try to bring it into the
world of non-fiction, right? So in
fiction, you'll hear writers saying,
"Oh, I I never think about the audience
and it does I don't care who reads my
book, you know, and that might actually
work in the world of art, but in the
world of non-fiction writing, it doesn't
work at all because when you have a
generic reader, well, honestly, like
generic readers don't exist. they just
don't exist. The the only thing that
exists are real people with specific
problems. Those are the people who give
their attention to our work. In the
world of fiction, it's a fantasy world.
It's the they're it's a conceptual
world. They're they're reading for
entertainment. In the world of
non-fiction, nobody reads this stuff for
entertainment. They read it to solve
problems. And so, in order to understand
what problems we're solving here, we
need to understand who are these people.
Now, I don't mean to lecture about this,
but I'm speaking from experience because
if you go back and watch my early
videos, you'll see a great example of
this. I think a lot of my earlier advice
was not specifically tailored to any one
type of writer. And because of that,
because I didn't really have a clear
sense of who the writers are on the
other side of the camera, well, a lot of
my earlier advice might have seemed a
little bit vague or just indiscriminate.
things like um you know write uh don't
edit while you're writing. Well, like
yeah, okay. But you know, once I started
meeting with more writers through these
coaching consultations, I started to
learn more about the specific problems
that writers were having. And so, you
know, maybe you're not you don't have a
specific coaching offer that'll let you
meet your readers, but it's still really
important to get a clear sense of who am
I writing this for? is that's going to
tell you what the problems are about and
you need to know what those problems are
in order to position your ideas as the
solution to those problems. So all it
always comes back to the reader and the
more specific you can get about that
reader, the better your writing will
become. This is the place where I begin
all my coaching sessions. You know, I I
was working with a writer recently who
had a whole um outline for a book and he
was basically ready to hit the ground
running and we just had to stop and set
it all aside and we took a three steps
back and began with who is this for?
Well, in fact, we begin before that
because when we're drafting a book, we
think, you know, what do you want to
achieve with this book? Because then we
can say, okay, well, who needs to read
this book in order for you to achieve
that goal? And that's when we can get
laser focused on the reader, right? Who
is this person who's going to read this
book? And how can I design the book in
order for that person to help me achieve
that desired outcome? So the point is
that like if you and here's the other
thing is like if you don't have a clear
sense of your reader, then if you're
working with somebody like me, like an
editor, then you're just going to be
receiving a lot of their opinions and
pet peeves. And like the the the editor
isn't the person who you're writing for.
Like a good editor is not going to be
beating you over the head with their pet
peeves about writing the way that your
high school English teacher did, right?
They're going to really help you get a
vision for who your reader is and to
question whether your language choices
are really connecting with that reader.
So if you don't know who your reader is,
then your editor is just forcing their
opinions onto you. Because in the world
of non-fiction, we are practicing the
art of persuasion, right? We have ideas
whether that is, you know, people should
take a certain set of actions or people
should uh take a certain set of beliefs.
But in either case, we are trying to
persuade the reader to accept our ideas.
And the thing is people don't like to
change their ideas and they definitely
don't like to change their behavior. So
there's going to be resistance from that
reader. And if we are to be effective at
persuading them, then we need to
anticipate their objections. If we're
not thinking about their objections and
their reservations, then it's just this
one-sided argument that falls flat. And
you've probably had this kind of
experience, like let's say you're
reading a book about an argument that
you care about, and the author has a set
of opinions that you don't really agree
with. Well, if they don't address your
objections to their opinions, then you
feel overlooked. Do you feel well I
don't accept this because they didn't
they didn't address my objection. They
didn't answer my question. I can think
about you know some controversial topics
and sometimes you you know you want to
read the work of people who you disagree
with. So you can't persuade people if
you don't know what their doubts are and
you just waste time proving stuff that
maybe they already believe while
ignoring the real obstacles to that
persuasion. So, if you really want to
persuade your reader, then it's great to
talk to them. It's great to interview
them if you can, to study their
responses to similar ideas, or you can
read the responses online. But no matter
what your writing should beat them to
their objections, right? You should
anticipate their objections at the
moment they object and and have your
counterargument right there waiting for
them. Good writing is like telepathy.
That's what Stephen King says, and I
think it's true. Step six is once you've
identified this community of readers,
then you want to start to learn their
secret language. Right? So, every
professional or social community has
coded language that signals this
matters. So, this is really fun. Again,
whenever I'm working with writers, I'll
have them pick four or five examples of
other prominent books or or writers in
that niche, and we'll find some standout
articles from them, and then we'll go
through and look for valuecoded
language. All the most successful
writers do this. They have these inside
co I mean all social groups have codes
slang and jar and that kind of thing but
there's a subset of that special
language which they use to signal value
in like super academic uh humanities
groups you know you'll see them say
words like problematic like this
problematizes many of us probably don't
like that particular word but you know
it is popular in the humanities when
they say oh let's problematize this
subject so that is an example of the
kind of valuecoded words that exist in
the humanities. But it doesn't matter if
it's in academia or content creation
online or you know substakistan or
whatever it is there are code words that
communities use to signal value and
problems. So, whatever niche you're
writing in, whatever reader community
you're writing for, you want to examine
some, you know, examples of prominent
texts in that field and look for
valuecoded language because you're going
to mimic those patterns. All right. Some
other classic valuecoded words are words
like however, critical, enables. These
words aren't just transitions. They're
value signals. It's like a flag. It's
like here's the important part. And if
you don't know this language or you
bring language from another field in
into this new domain, then your ideas
just aren't going to land. So you really
want to be almost like an
anthropologist. You know, you're reading
through the kind of prominent texts in
this community and you're looking for
that inside language that they use to
signal value and status to each other.
All right, it's really good to keep a
running document of words that you find
in this reader community because those
are the words that will make your
readers pay attention. All right, the
seventh step to writing without AI is to
focus on what your words do, not what
they say. And this is a big thing that
AI advocates miss. Right? A lot of these
people who are so excited about AI, they
say, "Wow, look at the amazing writing
that AI can produce." And when you
really come down to it, I think what
these people must believe is that words
just have fixed meanings. And so the
fact that a computer can produce these
words is just remarkable because there's
nothing under that. It's just the words
and the patterns. That's what counts.
But what I'm trying to say is that
there's a layer beneath that and those
are functions, right? the same sentence
can perform completely different
functions depending on where it's placed
in a text. So, for example, take a
phrase like uh sales were down 15%.
Right? That could be a problem, that
could be evidence, that could be
background information. It all depends
on what you as the writer need it to do.
When you only think about the content,
you miss how your readers are actually
processing the information. And this is
what the AI advocates just don't
understand because they end up with
these pages and pages of words in these
beautiful patterns that don't actually
perform reader functions. They don't
answer reader questions. They don't
anticipate reader expectations. They're
not thinking about a reader. They're
just arranging words in patterns. So the
way to fix this is to think about not
what your sentence says, but what is the
sentence doing? Right? So, you want to
design every sentence almost like a tile
in a path. Something that's moving the
reader from point A where they are at
the beginning of the text to point B
where you want them to be. Every
sentence and every paragraph is a tile
along that path. And if you can't tell
me, you know, if we're editing or
something, if you can't say, here's the
job that this sentence is doing, right?
This sentence is contrasting from the
previous idea. this sentence is
introducing a problem, an objection from
the reader, whatever. If you can't
identify the job of that sentence or
that paragraph, delete it. All right, so
that was the foundation out of the way.
And we're probably going to unpack a few
of those ideas a little bit later on in
the video, but now what I really want to
get to is the process. We need to know
actually how to perform this writing
because a lot of you who are using AI in
your writing are probably doing it
because you think I don't have time to
write. But here's what's actually
happening. You're making writing way
harder than it needs to be. You're
trying to think and write for readers at
the same time, which is complete
torture. So, the steps that follow are
going to show you the two draft writing
system that's going to cut your writing
time in half. The first draft is just
for you and it's going to be the space
in which you can generate your own
ideas. And the second draft is for
readers. And when you stop trying to do
both at once, your writing suddenly
becomes way easier. So step eight is to
give yourself permission to write
terrible first drafts. A lot of writers
start off saying, you know, I I don't
know what to write about. I don't have
any interesting ideas or I haven't lived
an interesting life. And I really don't
buy it. And I'm I'm not even just trying
to be like a rahrh writing coach. You
can do it. I really do mean everybody.
Everybody has their own ideas. This is
kind of a deeper point about knowledge
creation. And we can get into this in
another video, but it's true. Every
human on earth has generated their own
knowledge. We all have something new to
say. So, I really don't buy it that like
I don't have anything to write about.
You definitely do. The problem is that
your ideas and your expertise and the
questions that you're working on, it's
too complex to sort out to to think in
your head. There's this image I remember
I'll put it up on the screen here from
God and Bach, which shows a kind of
cognitive map. It's like a depiction of
the inside of somebody's head and it has
these strings making these connections
between these, you know, very loosely
formed concepts and ideas and it looks
like a plate of spaghetti. Honestly, I
think that's what the inside of our mind
looks like, right? It's a total mess. We
we think we have opinions, but we we
have these, you know, halfbaked and not
fully formed things floating around. And
it's not until we bring it up into
language that they actually become
something that resembles a coherent
thought. So before writing your
expertise you have but it's just
floating around in this kind of soup. So
you need to bring it out and you need to
use writing in order to give it this
kind of shape and coherence. But if you
try to write perfectly while you're
still thinking then you'll do both
badly. So you really need that first
draft to work through your ideas and
make your own connections. This is a
messy iterative process through which
you know there's a lot of crap that
comes up that's never going to see the
light of day and a lot of it is just
going to be evidence of your own
confusion. But you write and you write
and you write so that you can start to
give your own thoughts some shape and
coherence. So so many writers will mix
up these two processes and these are two
different writing patterns, right? The
first one is writing for you. It's
trying to sort out your own confusion.
The second one is trying to present
these ideas to readers in a way that
they will find coherent and logical and
acceptable. And these are two different
systems. So we really have to keep them
as separate and distinct as possible.
The first draft belongs to you. So, make
it as messy as you need. Follow your own
natural thought processes. Ask
questions. Think out loud. Don't worry
about contradictions. Just note them and
come back to them later. Don't worry
about readers at this point. You're not
trying to publish anything. You're just
trying to get your ideas out there onto
the page so that you can see them and
start making sense of them. It's like
writers are worried if readers will
understand what they think. And it's
like you don't even know what you think.
So, how can you worry about readers
worrying about that, right? Step nine is
to start to understand the difference
between writing patterns and reading
patterns. So the way that you think
interferes with how readers process
information, right? So think about
patterns abstractly here. Like the way
that you're writing, you're going to be
developing your ideas, you know, in in
these kind of patterns. But when readers
come to your text, they have a different
set of patterns. They're using your text
differently. And if you write your text
using writer patterns, then readers are
not going to be able to interpret it or
it's going to take them a lot of work to
interpret it, right? It's going to
interfere with their reading process,
right? Those messy first drafts, you
can't write them using reader patterns
because you don't even know what you
think yet. So, you're not going to put
your thesis up here because you don't
even know what the answer to the
question is. So, you're not going to
discover the answer to the question
until you get to the bottom of the page.
But now you've got to adapt this into
reader patterns. So the point here is to
understand what are reader patterns and
how can you make sure that your writing
patterns aren't interfering with their
reading patterns? Because when readers
hit these interference patterns, it
slows them down and they get frustrated
and they walk away from your text
thinking that it's just not clear,
right? They don't really give you
anything specific. They don't say, "You
interfered with my reading patterns."
they just say, "Oh, the writer isn't
very clear or it was disorganized or
something like that." What they're
saying is that they didn't know how to
use the text. They couldn't find the
information that they were looking for.
So, the thing to look for is a certain
set of patterns that are typical among
writers, you know, working through their
first draft. One of them would be
chronological organization, right? Which
is the process through which you, the
writer, discovered things, right? First
you discovered this source, then you had
this new idea, then you had a question
come up, right? That's your process of
working through this essay or this text.
But you that that pattern of
organization is not very useful to a
reader who is trying to find the answer
to a question, right? Another one is
when writers have a lot of background
information at the beginning. And again,
readers kind of want the meat and
potatoes up front and then for you to
unpack those as they go. So there are
these different patterns that belong to
the writer and the reader and you want
to learn to identify them and to keep
them distinct from each other. And once
you're able to identify these writing
and reading patterns, then step 10 is to
completely
rewrite your draft. Now why am I
emphasizing that word completely? Well,
most people like to revise their draft,
right? They've got their thinking draft.
Call that draft one. And they just
think, "Oh, I just need to move this
paragraph up here and semicolon there
and ta, it's all done." No, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no. Start a new document.
Okay? The first one is for you. And I
really mean that. It's just for you. So
don't try to copy and paste from that.
That thing is a mess. That's your own
thought process. Right now, what you
want to now that you have all the work
done, you want to write a fresh from the
reader's perspective. How are they going
to move through this text? Right? We
don't want to bring in any of those
writer patterns into this new text. So,
we're going to completely rewrite this
draft. And the way to do that is to
start with the idea of like, where is my
reader now? like what is driving them to
pick up this essay or you know read this
substack or open this book like why are
they interested in this something about
the title what's going on in their life
that would make them interested in this
title what's going to get them through
the first sentence what's going to get
them through the first paragraph right
how do I move them from where they are
now to where I would like them to be
again as we mentioned earlier we're
going to think of this text not as a
repository for information, but as a
path. It's like it's like a guided tour
that we're going to move them through,
but that can only happen when we really
think about where they are and what they
believe and what objections they're
going to have and how we can swiftly
move through that as a guide. You know,
not as an adversary or anything like
that, but how are we going to usher them
to this newfound value that we've
discovered through our own writing? And
in order to think about how to shape
this second draft for the reader, we
need to talk about structure because a
lot of writers are paralyzed because
they want their book or their article to
be perfect. So they just throw in
everything they know. They want to be
exhaustive and complete. But this of
course can be quite overwhelming,
especially for readers who again just
come to our text with one simple thing.
They just want the answer to a question
that they care about. And so when we
throw in all this extra information that
makes it complete and exhaustive, well
based on their purposes and their
reading patterns, all that information
becomes, well, frankly, useless and
overwhelming. And so in the steps that
follow, I'm going to give you a problem
solution framework that's going to let
you organize your ideas around the
problems of your reader. And this is a
great way to take the guesswork out of
structure. you don't have to agonize
anymore over, you know, how long should
this paragraph be or should I break up,
you know, these this into two sections
or anything like that. You're going to
know because it's all about your reader
and the way that they develop their
understanding of your solution to their
problem. Right? So, the first step to
building this problem solution
architecture is to always start with
what's broken. All right? So, a lot of
writers will open their text with
background information or context
because that's how they learned the
topic. But of course, readers don't care
about your learning journey. What they
need is to have their problem solved.
This background information is so
inconvenient. Like, as a bit of a
analogy here, do you remember like in
the blog days when um you know bloggers
they would make money by how long you
would spend on their blog because you
would see more ads. And so you'd go
online to, you know, you try to get a
recipe and you'd have to scroll through,
you know, all all this text this writer
would write uh this whole history of
their grandmother and where this recipe
came from and the old country and all
this kind of stuff that I mean you would
just scroll through that kind of
impatiently because you just wanted the
recipe. But honestly, if you go on
Substack or like a lot of the kind of
independent publishing platforms these
days, that is what a lot of the text
feels like. Now, they're not doing it
for ads, but they're doing it because
they think they need to give readers
background information. And readers hate
that. Just like in the recipes, readers
don't care about background information.
In fact, when you open your essay, your
your your text, whatever it is you're
writing with background information, it
forces the reader to ask a question. Why
should I care about this? Right? That's
that's that's the first question readers
are trying to answer when they start
reading your text. Why should I care?
And so we need to think about problem
solution architecture to answer that
question clearly right from the
beginning. And there are some keywords
that you can use from this. You know,
words like despite or however or but
those are classics. Uh as mentioned
before, each community has their own
special set of words that signal
problems and value. So, it's great if
you can mine those from other successful
writers in your niche. But basically,
what you're trying to do here is to use
problem language to signal to the reader
that this text is going to address the
problem that they're dealing with. Step
12 is we want to organize everything,
not just the introduction, but the rest
of the piece as well around these
problems and solutions. Right? So when
you don't use this problem solution
structure, then readers can't figure out
why your ideas matter. All right? So of
course the whole text is going to be
about a problem, but those problems are
often composed of subpros. All right? So
imagine if you have a business, right?
You're not making money. Well, that's a
problem, but that problem is going to be
composed of subpros like I can't get new
clients. Okay? And then that system
itself is going to be composed of
subpros such as um you know where are my
new leads coming from? How am I booking
them on calls? There are these
subsystems within it. So any problem is
going to be composed of subpros and
those subpros are going to correspond
with the paragraphs and the sections of
your piece. So again, you've done all
your discovery work, all your knowledge
generation over in your writer's draft,
but in your reader draft, we're not
taking any of that yet. We're thinking
about, okay, what's the problem I've
solved? Where's the reader at right now?
And what are the subpros that I need to
move them through in order to accept my
final solution to this problem? Now,
honestly, this problem solution
structure is a bit of a conceit because
we're not thinking about reader problems
whenever we're doing our writing. Our
writing is expressive. It's free.
There's a lot of discovery in it. You
you can come up with so much new
knowledge in that freewriting session.
But whenever we come over here to the
reader draft, well, we we don't take any
of that. We now need to think about the
outline of the problems that our reader
has to go through. And we need to think,
okay, how can I mobilize my ideas as the
solution to any of these problems or
subpros? So here we're just thinking
about an outline. What are the what's
what's the problem solution architecture
that my reader needs to go through in
order to accept my final idea, my
solution to the problem, aka a thesis,
right? Step 13 is learning how to
disagree without making enemies. Now,
honestly, I'm not the best at this. I
can be a little bit flip on the
internet. So, take this all with a grain
of salt. But it is something that we all
have to learn because if your ideas are
valuable, then they are going to be
overturning the ideas of others. You are
going to be disagreeing with other
people. If you're not, then you're kind
of off in a corner having a conversation
with yourself. Right? All writing, I
mean, I I I generally like to think
about writing the way I think about any
social um interaction. Like think about
speaking, right? For your writing to be
for your speaking to be valuable, you
need to enter into a discussion, right?
Some people are having a conversation
about something and if you want them to
perceive your speech as valuable. Well,
you don't start having a discussion
about whatever it is you want to talk
about. You kind of pick up where the
last guy left off and you say, "Oh,
well, Mr. Soandso has an interesting
idea and you know, Mrs. So and so had a
had a great contribution, but here's
something that I think both of you are
overlooking, which is right, that would
be a polite way to enter into a
conversation. A bad way to enter into
that conversation would be just to
ignore what everybody was talking about
and kind of say, well, you're stupid and
you're wrong and you're ugly and here's
my idea. But honestly, I mean, if you go
on Twitter or like a lot of these
places, that's what that's what a lot of
us do, myself included, right? So where
was I? Okay. So, if your ideas are going
to be valuable, then it means you're
going to be disagreeing with other
people, right? Your ideas are going to
be positioned against the ideas of
others. So, if you're right, it means
that somebody else is wrong or at least
that their understanding is incomplete.
But in either case, you're going to be
challenging the existing thinking to
create new knowledge. Okay? But if you
just walk in the room and say you're
wrong, well, it's going to make people
quite defensive. And I see this a lot.
Like just a quick example, there's this
um fantastic book by an academic who's
um living in my city here in Busousan,
South Korea um called The Cleanest Race.
He's a North Korea scholar and it's an
amazing book. Oh my god, it's so good
because um you know, he's kind of
entering into this academic space where
people are arguing about North Korea and
some people think that North Korea is a
totalitarian state and other people
think it's a fascist communist state and
and whatever. They kind of have their
academic disagreements about this, but
he comes out swinging at everybody. He's
like, "You're all wrong." And he he like
the tone in the book is just so um
punchy and full of moxy. And he has this
like really um unique approach to
understanding North Korea, which is to
analyze their propaganda. This is an
example that's coming in off the top of
my head, but the point here is that
here's an example of somebody who
disagrees with everybody. It's like he's
like Germany in World War II. Like he's
going to war with the world, but he
doesn't pull any punches. And I don't
really know how well that's gone for
him. I I can say as a reader, it's a
hell of a book to read, but that style
um can make it challenging if you want
to use your writing socially, right? If
you want to use your writing to advance
your career, make new relationships,
have your ideas accepted by a community
of peers, you need to learn how to
modulate your claims and show difference
even if you disagree with the kind of
big kahunas. Um, you don't always have
to do this. I mean, you can be whatever
kind of writer you want. But the point
is that it's if if if you don't show
deference to the kind of ideas of the
group, then it doesn't matter how right
you are, as I think this academic is. I
think his book is excellent, but I can
imagine he got a lot of push back from
his own discourse community just for the
tone, not for the quality of his ideas,
but just for the tone that he brings to
it. So, you can't really advance the
conversation if you can't disagree
effectively. So, the way to do this is
to acknowledge the value of the existing
thinking first. I call this a
concession, right? So you've got like
you you can imagine in constructing your
problem you've got a status quo which is
the way that things are or the kind of
consensus that everybody agrees with.
And before you dismantle that consensus
to show what's wrong with it, you want
to give a concession. Well, what's right
about it? Even if you fundamentally
disagree with it, you can put yourself
in their shoes and say, "Well, what has
been useful about this idea? What what
what has this belief helped these
believers do or accomplish? Give a tip
of your hat to the idea before you
totally come off the top ropes to
dismantle it because then you're going
to introduce a destabilizing condition
that shows the problem and that's the
place where your writing really gains
its value. Step 14 is going to show you
how to build better problems using
research, real research. Okay? So many
people these days are using AI to do
their research because I just think that
like using AI in your research is such a
great case of confirmation bias. Like
you go to your chat GPT and you say hey
chat GPT you know what is all the
evidence that I don't know the earth is
flat and it's going to say well here's
all you know even if it says like it
seems unlikely it's going to give you
what you asked for. So, I don't
necessarily think that people who are
using AI to do their research and
especially their literature reviews and
academia, don't get me started, um, it's
not leading to the best results. And so,
here's how you can actually use research
to build better problems because a lot
of writers whenever they're using
outside research, they'll bring in
citations, they'll use a quote, and
they'll just say, you know, Smith says
this, Jones argues that, right? they're
basically just bringing this into the
text to show that they've read an
interesting book or like it's not useful
to the reader. It doesn't create value.
When you bring in outside research, what
do you expect the reader to do with it?
That's a question that I think too often
goes unanswered. And when that question
goes unanswered, then what you start to
get is just a lot of citations that
readers don't care about. I forget about
academia. You know, you see this on
Substack. Somebody says, "Oh, I read
this interesting book or here's a quote
from a writer I like." But again,
readers don't care, right? They don't
care what book you've read. You need to
show them what what do you want this
quote to do? Right? That's that's the
question we want to ask here is like,
what is the function of this quote?
What's the function of this citation?
How is it moving the reader forward on
this path from point A to point B? So,
the way to fix this is just to use
research to create tension and
contradiction, right? Like it's great if
you can say something like Smith's
findings conflict with Jones's
conclusion which creates uncertainty,
right? Something like that. Like if you
can show that there's this problem in
the field, right? Here's a writer that
we all like and here's a piece of
scholarship that you know kind of and
and now look right they don't agree.
Okay, that's useful. So you want to use
research in a way that makes situations
more complex, more problematic, and not
just more informed. Right? Moving on
from structure, which is like the
problem solution structure of your
writing. We're now going to talk about
organization. All right. Now, this isn't
going to be like a finger wagging
grammar class about your sentences and
paragraphs, but I honestly think that
like the 8020 for clarity in writing
comes down to organization at the
sentence level and the paragraph level.
If you can just learn a few simple
tricks about the way that you organize
the information in your sentences and
the way those kind of scale up into
paragraphs and you can be strategic
about the way that you set this stuff
up, you create what's called flow. When
you understand organization, you create
that elusive thing that writers are
always chasing called flow. Flow is a
very simple principle. You get it from
just a few basic tricks that I'm going
to show you in this section. And the
first trick is just to keep your
subjects consistent. All right? So
there's this myth out there that we
should avoid repetition in our writing.
And so in keeping with this myth,
writers believe that they should vary
their subjects, the grammatical subject,
like subject, verb, object. They think
you shouldn't repeat anything in that
subject position. So my name's William.
I mean, you can imagine a paragraph that
says, you know, William recorded a video
and then William wrote a script and
William needed a drink of water and that
kind of thing. According to this myth,
that style of writing is bad. But I'm
here to say that it's fantastic. Having
a consistent subjects creates a really
smooth reading experience. Okay? When
you vary it just for the sake of
variety, you make readers work harder to
follow the logic and development of your
ideas. The way that I illustrate this in
my writing class is to ask students to
imagine that they're watching a
performance like a play or a musical,
right? Although there might be a lot of
um different characters in the
production, at any given moment there
will only be two or maybe three
characters on stage. And that's because
any more than that and it becomes
overwhelming. You can't keep track of
all their relationships with each other.
Well, it's the same thing at the level
of grammar, right? If you're constantly
varying the element that's in your
subject position, then it's kind of like
you're re like every sentence tells a
story. So imagine every sentence to be
like I don't know uh an action. It it is
every sentence is an action. It has a
verb in it. So every sentence is a kind
of key action in the development of this
musical. And you can imagine if the
subject is always varying, it's like a
different character performing a
different action throughout the musical.
and the viewers in the audience are just
kind of darting back and forth. They're
like, "What is this scene about?" Right?
So, the way to fix this is to pick two
or maybe three main subjects for each
section or each paragraph and just like
don't just vary them for the sake of
variety. You should pick one and it's
almost like you have the camera focused
on it.
Keep your focus on that subject. And
each sentence and each clause is going
to stay focused until you decide, I'm
going to move the focus now over to this
other key character in this section.
Right? Whenever you're strategic about
what you put into the subject position,
you help your readers keep focus on what
matters most. Right? Now, of course,
that can get a little bit overkill. So
step 16 is to train your readers to
understand your system for naming. So
what do I mean? Well, like of course you
wouldn't want a full paragraph or you
know even a whole section that says
William did this and William did that
and William did that. Like of course
that's going to get monotonous. So there
is good reason to vary the subject
without referring to different entities.
Like you don't just kind of want to keep
saying William, William, William. You of
course want to say he, but you know now
William and he, that gets a little bit
drawn out. So you're going to need to
develop a naming convention, some system
of names that you're going to use to
refer to that single entity. But of
course, readers need to understand your
system or they're going to get confused.
Like if you start introducing random
ways to refer to me as like the English
professor and the YouTuber and if that
comes, you know, mid text, then readers
are going to be like, who's the what who
is this? Right? So, you need to train
them. You need to get them ready for
that kind of at the introduction of this
character or this subject because if
readers can't tell whether you're
talking about the same thing or
different things, then they're going to
waste a lot of mental energy on trying
to sort that out. So, the way to fix
this is to establish your variations,
like the various ways that you refer to
that entity early in the piece. So let's
say for example you have a section that
you're developing and the focus is going
to be on customer retention software.
Then you need to show readers that
customer retention software and these
platforms refer to the same thing before
you start using this naming system. You
want to train them early on in the text
so that you can keep using it
consistently throughout what follows.
Right? So how do you choose the elements
that go in the subject position? Right?
What are the characters that you're
going to keep your focus on? Well,
again, surprise, surprise, it all comes
down to organizing the text around
reader problems. All right, so writers,
when they're just not thinking about the
way they're organizing information at
the sentence level, then honestly, the
elements that appear in the subject
position will be quite random. But
readers follow problem-solving logic way
easier. Like if you're consistently
focused on that problem solution
structure and you organize your subjects
accordingly, then oh god, readers will
just sail through your text. But when
sections are not organized to solve
these problems, then it can feel quite
random and readers can't really figure
out where you're going or why any of
this matters because all these random
characters keep coming onto the stage.
So, the way to fix this is to ask,
"What's the next problem my reader needs
solved?" And then to structure the
sections in the order that readers will
encounter those problems. Of course, you
want to use transitions to show the
logical relationships between these
moves and have the elements in the
subject position be consistent with the
appearance of those problems and
solutions. All right. So, I've been
teasing this section as we've been
going, but now it is time to talk about
what really counts in your writing,
which is value. In this section, I'm
going to show you how to create value in
your writing. Because a lot of writers
are worried about whether readers will
actually want to read this, right?
They're afraid that their ideas are just
going to be ignored or dismissed as
being generic or something that's not
special, not unique, and something that
everybody already knows. As I've been
saying, I really don't buy it for
philosophical reasons. I truly believe
that everybody has their own set of
unique knowledge. We've all generated
knowledge that the world deserves and we
can share that through our writing. But
we need to know how to position those
ideas in a way that readers will
perceive as valuable. So that's what
this section is all about. The first
thing you want to do is master the words
that signal importance. As we've already
mentioned, there are specific code words
that we use to signal value and
importance. And there are big ones like
however and but and the problem is, but
there are also community specific ones
that we are going to learn and practice.
And when writers just aren't thinking
about this, they're not thinking about
problems. they're not thinking about the
way they're signaling to their reader
importance or the appearance of problems
or destabilizing situations. Well, then
the writing just feels so generic. And
again, I've been kind I don't mean to.
I've been kind of picking on Substack in
this video, but I I see a lot of AI
writing there and I see a lot of generic
writing there, right? People are writing
about topics that they're interested in,
but they're not thinking about how to
mobilize that interest into a way that
readers will perceive as valuable. I'm
not saying that, you know, the ideas out
there uh that we see in the world of
self-publishing and and online aren't
valuable, but what I think people really
need to think about is how they can
position those ideas to be perceived as
valuable by their readers. And whenever
I help writers build this list, I
basically like to break it up into three
columns. All right? So, you want to look
for opportunity words. That might be
words like enables or becomes, right?
There are cost words, something like
prevents or disrupts. And there are
urgency words like critical or crucial.
Now, again, there's going to be a lot of
variety in this depending on your niche.
So, it's really important to examine
four to five uh examples of prominent
writing in your niche. The kind of
people who have the audience that you
want to speak to, you want to look at
their writing and look for language that
signals either opportunity or benefits,
cost, and urgency. Right? Find that
vocabulary and then use those
strategically in your own writing.
Right? Step 19. You want to make the
value obvious in every paragraph. All
right. So, whenever I talk about
structure and organization, like it's
important to understand, again, none of
this is about rules, but it's to
understand reading patterns. And
readers, one of the patterns that
readers use whenever they're
interpreting a text is that they look to
certain structural locations to find
certain pieces of information. Like at
the sentence level, readers expect to
find information about the action of
course in the verb, right? And they
expect to find information about the
location or the time in the adverb or
prepositional phrase. So similarly,
readers are looking at the paragraph
level to find value. Now, where are
readers looking for it, right? Are they
looking at the end of the paragraph?
Sometimes, but gen are they looking in
the middle of the paragraph? No, they're
looking usually at the start of the
paragraph. Now, you probably hate to
hear that because in your high school,
you got hit over the head with all these
lessons about uh topic sentences and
claims and everything, but I'm just
saying that every se every paragraph and
every section should at the top of it
indicate the value proposition, right?
Because you're kind of making an
agreement with the reader. you're
saying, "Okay, well, here's a long
section of text, and I know you're very
busy, but if you read this, here's the
value that you're going to get." Now,
that's not like a copywriting trick.
That's just the kind of social contract
that we're entering into with readers.
They're trading us their attention for
value. And so, we need to reassure them
that we're going to be providing value,
and we need to follow through on those
promises. So, what we want to do is at
the beginning of every paragraph and and
larger section, um, however you've
broken up your text, you want to make
sure that the value is right where the
reader is expecting to find it, which in
most cases is going to be at the start.
In some kind of in some cases, if you
want to be uh kind of storyteller and
kind of lead them on, you could locate
the value proposition at the end if you
if you really want to kind of use
advanced skills. Probably should not be
buried in the middle. That's the point
here, right? So, this is something I
usually practice with clients who I'm
editing for, right? I'll have them
circle the value words and just circle
them all throughout the text. And what I
like to see is a lot of them loaded at
the beginning and then at least one
value word at the start of every
paragraph, right, in that first
sentence. Because that's a way of
diagnosing problems. If we see a large
section where we can't circle any value
words, any of these problem words that
signal urgency or or problems or or
benefits, well, then we know that we
need to, you know, we have a problem
that we need to fix. Step 20, home
stretch. We want to make the costs and
the benefits personal, right? It's not
really enough to sketch out a problem.
We need to show the reader the
consequence of not fixing this problem.
And that could be something personal to
the reader or something that will affect
a cause or a situation that the reader
cares about. So again, this all comes
down to the reader, right? So we're
talking about the difference between
saying uh this creates some
inconsistencies or this is a
contradiction, right? That feels just so
academic and like conceptual and
abstract. Contrast that with saying,
"This prevents you from retaining your
best customers." All right, that's
urgent. That's something that the reader
can feel. That's food taken off the
table and out of the mouth of the
reader. They understand what the problem
is because we've identified the
consequence of not solving that problem.
All right? So, as you're structuring
your problems, you want to make the
consequences of those problems specific
and personal. And you can do that. You
can take the same problem and identify
the different consequences based on the
different reader groups you might have.
In fact, academics will do this.
They'll, you know, they'll have their
research, their argument, and one day
they might present it before a community
of their their colleagues. And of
course, the stakes of that problem are
going to be different. So the
consequences of that problem are going
to be one thing and it's going to be
abstract and conceptual and that kind of
thing. But then they might go down the
street and present it at a local
community center where people who have
never read anything in this field. Well,
they can a good academic is somebody who
can still talk about their field of
expertise and show why it matters to the
granny's and the children down at the
local library. Right? So, it's the same
problem, but they've adapted the
consequences and the stakes of that
problem to match their audience. And
there are two sides of this, right? You
can show the cost of those problems. So
you can say you know this problem will
limit your ability to do something or
you can show what your solution to that
problem enables them to do. Right? This
idea allows you to do something. The
next phase of the expert writing system
is to understand reader psychology. So
when you start writing and sharing your
stuff online, it can often feel like
you're shouting into the void and you
wonder, how do I actually connect with
my audience? Well, if you're not hearing
anything back, then probably you're
struggling to understand what your
readers actually want. And so maybe
people are reading what you've written,
but it feels disconnected and it's hard
for you to build a relationship with
your readers unless you understand them.
But when you start to understand the way
that readers think and what motivates
them, you can learn to anticipate their
objections and build authority without
coming across as arrogant. Again, this
is all social stuff, but we forget about
the kind of social behavior that happens
between readers and writers. So, step 21
is to beat readers to their objections.
Like, a lot of writers will just present
their ideas assuming that readers are
just going to accept them. But, as any
psychologist will tell you, people do
not like to change their ideas. They
don't want to hear that they're wrong
about something or that they have to do
something differently. So we can assume
that our readers are actively looking
for reasons to doubt us especially when
our ideas require any effort or change
in lifestyle or behavior. And when you
don't address these objections then it
basically undermines your whole
argument. Like this is actually
something they teach in sales too. You
need to design a sales letter, a kind of
sales script to address all of the
objections, right? Because the buyer is
going to have objections to spending
money. Oh, I need to talk to my wife.
Oh, I need to wait until I get paid. Oh,
you know, they they they're always going
to find some reason to not part with
their money. And if you don't have a way
of meeting all those objections, all of
them, then they're going to they're
going to find one and that's going to be
the one that gets them off the hook. So
similarly when you are trying to you
know not sell something but sell readers
on your idea and your argument then you
need to handle all of their objections
and if you miss any of them then they
basically just think that you don't
understand the situation and they're not
going to accept your ideas or
suggestions. So the fix here is for
every major claim you want to anticipate
the top three objections. And this is
pretty easy because there are basically
only three objections that you ever hear
to a new idea, right? It could be there
are causes to this problem other than
the ones that you have identified. There
are counter examples that contradict the
examples that you've provided. So you've
left out some evidence or I don't define
this term in the same way that you
define it. All right. So there might be
some other ways of disagreeing, but
generally if you look at uh
counterarguments, it's usually going to
fall in one of those three buckets. So
why don't you just anticipate that? For
every claim you make, try to answer
those questions before they come up,
right? Step 22 is you want to make
readers feel personally invested in your
writing, right? Because when you write
abstractly and impersonally, then well,
on the plus side, it can make you sound
authoritative and professional. And
that's something that's often
recommended in professional circles. But
honestly, there's nothing wrong with
using like personal pronouns, you and I,
in the text. It can create a personal
relationship with your reader. And I
think that's that's quite persuasive
because if if the reader feels a
connection with the um the authoral
voice, you know, the the writer in the
text, then they're going to be a lot
more likely to accept his suggestions
and to be persuaded by his ideas. So, I
would say don't be afraid of using
personal language. You can inject humor.
You can talk about personal anecdotes.
The thing I want to stress here is that
writing is social. So, we don't need
these stuffy rules about, you know, how
to be impersonal in your writing and how
to come off professionally. Your
language choices determine the
relationship that you have with your
reader. And if readers feel good about
you, that is you, the the you that lives
on the page, then they will be more
likely to be persuaded by your ideas.
So, of course, don't overdo it. Um, you
know, I I I read a book recently that
was just filled with uh the pronoun you
and uh it was almost like the writer had
written like a journal to himself. Like
it was like he was talking to himself,
you need to lock in and you need to
focus and this kind of stuff. So it can
be done poorly. Um don't overdo it, but
I would say don't be afraid of using
personal language because that can
create a bond between you and your
reader if done well. Step 23 is when we
need to find a healthy balance between
sounding confident without sounding too
arrogant because we're in the business
of persuasion here in non-fiction
writing. And so we need to be
convincing. We need to show the reader
that we're quite confident in our ideas,
but without going too far with that. And
there's a certain set of language
choices we can do to get those ideas
across. This comes up with a lot of
academics who I work with whose writing
is filled with what we call uh hedges.
So words like perhaps or uh verbs like
seems you know could be those are kinds
of hedges which modulate their level of
confidence in the strength of the claim.
And those are the language items that we
use in order to control our level of
confidence. But we also have to use the
right level of confidence for the
audience. And I think, you know,
scientists and and academics are
generally a lot more careful in making
their claims because they're writing for
a community that kind of exists based on
this uh culture of peer review, right?
They're expecting their audience to like
vehemently attack their ideas because
that's part of their process of truthf
finding. But it doesn't really work when
we export those language uh behaviors
into other niches and domains. And if
you use too many of them, then it's
going to undermine your ideas, right?
Like a many other audiences outside of
academia really don't like that and and
don't respect that level of hedging,
right? It makes you seem unconfident in
your ideas. And why would they listen to
somebody who's not confident in their
ideas? So again, this is a social thing.
It's a cultural thing. It's it's this
kind of um being careful about the
strength of your claims is respected in
certain cultures and academia, but it
really doesn't work in many other
fields. But on the other side, we can't
go too far with our level of confidence
because then you just come across as
arrogant and people dismiss your ideas
out of hand without even considering
them cuz you sound like a jackass. So we
need to balance these. How can we do
that? Well, I think in general
non-fiction writing, you want to make
direct confidence statements and always
make sure that your claims are supported
by evidence that your reader is going to
accept. Now, again, depending on your
field, that evidence can come from a
variety of different sources, but every
claim, like I always kind of say that a
claim or an idea has three parts.
There's a truth claim which is your
attempt to say something true about the
world and then that is going to be
supported by evidence and then reasoning
what we call in uh in the field of uh
writing we we call them warrants you
know explanations of how the evidence
supports the claim. So you're always
going to need those three pieces for any
idea. So in your claims, be confident,
be stridident, but always make sure that
they're backed up by solid evidence and
clear reasoning that readers will follow
and accept. Now, whenever I get writers
started with this system of expert
writing, they can still deal with this
fear of publishing. They might have
written two or three pieces, but they're
afraid of sharing it because they don't
want to put any work out there that
damages their reputation. These writers
would rather not publish than risk
looking incompetent or being judged. And
it's funny because they end up with this
kind of paradox, these two fears, right?
The fear that nobody is going to read
anything I write and the fear that
everybody is going to read what I write
and they're going to judge me for it.
Well, both of those cannot be true at
the same time. So, why don't we
dismantle this second fear? The fear
that everybody is going to judge you by
giving you some quality control steps
that you can follow. This is going to be
a systematic way to ensure that your
writing meets the standards of your
readership before anybody sees it. So
you're not going to be secondguessing
yourself. You know what your audience is
expecting and you're delivering that.
That's quality control. And the first
step in this system is to audit
everything for what's that key word?
Value. But it's really important. So
stick with me. So editors like me are
famous for just cutting, cutting,
cutting. We say cut this, delete that,
move this over there. Right? and and
writers can feel like, well, that's
really hard to accept because you put so
much work into this. So, what I deal
with a lot is writers who want to keep
things in their draft, in their
manuscript because it's either true or
interesting. But all this cutting from
my perspective comes down to value.
What's the value? How is this step going
to provide value to the reader? How is
it going to solve their problem? How is
it going to develop their understanding
of the problem? How does this sentence,
this section, this paragraph create
value? And if you can't answer that
question, if you're just including stuff
in your writing because it's true or
it's interesting or just because you
wrote it and so, hey, I put the work in,
I want to keep it in. Well, what are you
actually doing? You are diluting the
impact of your ideas and you're wasting
your reader's time. The most precious
resource you have as a writer is your
reader's attention. So if you're
fighting to keep weak content in your
manuscript, it's wasting space and it's
also undermining the best ideas that you
have. So whenever I'm editing
manuscripts, here's the question that I
ask and you can just beat me to it and
do it yourself, which is why should my
reader care, right? What problem does
this paragraph, this quote, this
section, what problem does it solve? So,
if you can't identify that value, either
rewrite it or delete it. Step 25, use
the so what test. Writers often assume
that their readers will understand why
the information matters or again, they
go to arguments like it's true or it's
interesting or they just want to leave
it in cuz it's neat. But the fact is, if
you don't spell it out, if you don't
link this information to the question,
so what? Then you're asking readers to
do unnecessary work. Like they can read
and they can interpret. And that's one
level of work. But if you're not making
clear connections between your ideas,
then you're ramping this up and having
them do this extra work of sorting out,
okay, well, why is this related to that?
And what's the point? What's the point
here? So what? And so that's the problem
that this so what test is meant to
solve. Every major point in your writing
should let readers easily answer the
question, what does this do for me? What
does it mean for me? Why should I care?
Now, if you're explaining your thinking
process instead of solving problems,
then it's time to rewrite it. The second
quality control check is to remove
everything that makes reading hard.
Tada! Fantastic point. No, but I'm
serious. We need to think about the
reading process. I think I remember
reading David Foster Wallace say
something about this uh in an interview
with Brian Garner. He said like good
writing basically just comes down to the
reader's cognitive experience. Like
there's work that they need to do in
order to decode our language into ideas
in their mind. And the easier that
decoding process is, the we say the the
better the writer is. But it's really
just a matter of making that
interpretation process as easy and
unambiguous as possible. So what we want
to do in this quality controls check is
to remove everything that makes that
process hard. All right. All right.
Easier said than done. What does that
actually mean? Well, as you know, the
language patterns that helped you think
in the writing process, they interfere
with the language patterns that help
readers process information. you both of
you are using the text differently and
so that makes reading feel difficult
because if you leave in these thinking
patterns, these writing patterns, you're
going to make that process of decoding
harder even when your ideas are good and
valuable. Now, when readers hit these
interference patterns, they slow down.
They get frustrated and that creates
negative associations with you and your
ideas. And so, what we want to do here
is remove writer focused language. So
that could be things like giving a lot
of background or chronological
organization or just explanations of
your thought processes and the kind of
steps that you went through in
discovering the solutions. We want to
remove those so that the text matches
the reader process of thinking through
these things. And what do I mean by
reader focused language patterns? Well,
that hearkens back to an earlier
section, but it has everything to do
with your problem architecture, right?
the way that you lay out the problem and
the process through which the reader
goes in understanding the causes and the
solutions to that problem. Step 27 is to
test your writing with real people. Now,
that could be an editor or beta readers,
but what it comes down to is you want to
see the reaction that people have with
your text because you can only guess
until you actually see somebody trying
to use your text as a reader. then you
never really know whether it's any good
or whether your ideas are coming
through. Now, of course, this can happen
in a lot of different ways. Writers know
they can share their work with other
people and get feedback and that's very
valuable. But a great example that I've
seen of this in practice is uh Paul
Millard, who has since published a book,
but when he was kind of developing the
materials for this book, The Pathless
Path, he did something great that I
really think all writers should try to
do, which is to connect with his
audience. He was writing, I think, on
Substack and he would have one-on-one
Zoom meetings with his readers. He
called them curiosity conversations. No
structure, no, you know, particular um
goal with these conversations, but he
would just meet them and talk to them
and learn about the things they were
interested in. And I think that's
fantastic because you want to know the
people who are resonating with your
work. As you really develop this kind of
uh avatar for your reader, your writing
becomes so much more focused to their
interests and their reading patterns.
So, anything you can do to you know like
often writers will share their work with
other writers because those are people
who we respect and we want to know you
know what they think of our craft. But
honestly, the best feedback that you can
get is from readers. And writers should
not be too shy to share their early work
and their drafts and their kind of messy
ide
with their audience because that's the
feedback that counts. It doesn't matter
what the editor thinks or what your what
your writer friends think of your paper.
They're not really the ones you're
writing for. It's your readers. So if
you have a kind of even smaller fledgly
audience, you share with them your best
work and see what they think about it
because their reaction is going to give
you details about the reading process
and the the reading patterns that they
use when they're going through your
text. And now for a quick fire bonus
round where I'm going to tell you some
writing habits that you can practice
daily, success indicators that tell you
that you're moving in the right
direction, and a practical guide to
start writing today. Daily habits.
Before writing, ask what specific value
am I creating? When you start writing,
begin with a reader problem, never
background. First drafts, write for your
thinking and ignore readers. Revision.
Completely rewrite for readers. Don't
just edit your first draft. Before
publishing, circle all the value
creation words. If there are large gaps
between them, you've got a problem. Now,
you know that you're practicing expert
writing. When readers actually do things
based on your writing, when you can
predict their objections before they
even think of them. When your writing
feels valuable to people who disagree
with you. When you write faster because
you know your reader reading patterns
and their secret codes. When people
share and reference your work online
because it's helpful to them. Now, look,
knowing these principles is just the
starting point. The real magic happens
when you put them into practice. But
here's what most people get wrong. They
try to apply all of these steps at once
and end up overwhelmed and paralyzed. So
watch this video next because it's going
to show you exactly how to implement
this system step by step, walking you
through the specific practice routine
that I developed that's a perfect
balance between creative discovery and
scientific precision, so you can start
writing with confidence instead of
constantly second-guessing yourself. So,
be sure to go check it out.